We're asked to
fill in the blanks
to complete the equation.
So they have 86.93
is equal to 5 tens
plus blank ones plus 9
tenths plus 3 hundredths.
So let me expand out
86.93 and just think
about how I could regroup the
value in the different places
so that I get
something more close
or exactly what we have
on the right-hand side.
So the 8 in 86.93,
that's in the tens place.
So it literally
represents 8 tens.
So I can write that down as 80.
The 6 in 86 represents 6 ones.
So I can write that down as 6.
Then the 9 in 86.93,
that's 9 tenths.
So I could write that down.
I could write this 9.
That's right of
the decimal place.
This is plus 9 tenths.
And then the 3 in 86.93, that
is in the hundredths place.
It represents 3 hundredths.
So this is plus 3 over 100.
So I've expanded out the
number that I have on the left.
Now let me write out what
they have on the right again.
So this is going to be equal
to-- they have 5 tens here.
So I'll write all the tens
places in this red color.
Then they have blank ones.
So I'm just going to
literally write out
a blank plus 9 tenths.
So the 9 tenths is still 9
tenths plus 3 hundredths.
So let me make sure
that we color code this.
So that's the 9 tenths.
This is the 5 tens.
That's the 50.
We have the blank ones.
That's this right
over here, 9 tenths.
And then finally we have the 3
hundredths, so plus 3 over 100.
So how do we get
the right-hand side
to be the exact same thing
as the left-hand side
by adjusting this blank?
Well, both sides
have a 3/100 on it,
both sides have a 9/10 on it.
And so what's really different
about the two sides is
on the left-hand
side-- let me do
this in a color we
can actually see.
On the left-hand side
you have an 80 plus a 6.
On the right-hand side you
have a 50 plus a blank.
So 80 plus 6 is clearly 86.
Well, what has to be
added to 50 to get to 86?
Well, you have to add 36.
So now both sides add
up to the same thing.
80 plus 6 is 86.
50 plus 36 is 86.
Then you have 9/10,
9/10, 3/100, 3/100.
Now, you might be saying, hey
wait, you wrote a 36 here.
Does this literally
means 36 ones?
And I will say yes, it
literally represents 36 ones.
This is the same
thing as 36 times 1.
So we can fill in
the blank here.
86.93 is equal to
5 tens plus 36 ones
plus 9 tenths plus 3 hundredths.
And I encourage
you to add this up.
You will get 86.93.
Now, what have we
essentially done here?
What we essentially did, if you
compare the 8 and the 5 right
over here, you see that we
took 3 from the tens place.
But taking 3 from the
tens place is essentially
taking 30 from the value
that it represents.
So we took 30 from
the tens place,
and we gave that 30
to the ones place.
So you had 86.
You take 30 away, you
have 50 in the tens place,
represented by this 5.
And then you give that 30 to
the ones place, you have 36.
You have 36 ones.